oh yeah has the modern maid always yeah
he's got no neck look at that Posterous
that is a preposterous neck yeah I feel
like if you had kicked him he might die
right it's not his head's not gonna stay
attached you snap that [ __ ] down yeah
look at Tysons day look at that yeah
Jesus he's like nippulini that was the
dark days right before that was the
court but when they were putting him in
jail for rape yeah did he do it
what does that article say if you have a
no I don't I don't believe he did I
might be wrong but that girl she falsely
accused someone of rape earlier yeah if
you have a thin neck your most likely a
beta male how about take out most likely
what how about just you are you are a
beta male who's out there ranch it with
a thin neck yeah your mom's house got
this guy you probably owe that net guy
damn long neck what do you mean that's
the longest who's this guy oh I thought
you belong I have seen that guy yeah I
thought you can't bring up that guy
who's been in the internet memes the
dude is now fighting mmm a black guy
whose neck starts at the top his head
and goes straight down is that real he's
got the craziest neck ever he's just had
a weird neck oh I thought it was just
like distorted oh oh that's real no
there's a bunch of pictures I've been
seeing that yeah I was just like oh they
just did the face I made it they didn't
do this that's do does a nutty neck you
know some girls have giant tits uh-huh
guys just a giant neck yeah I mean some
people isn't him I'm a huge hands he's
gonna start fighting MMA but quits he
from I don't know why Florida wait I bet
he's from Florida
look at him leave his neck man he got
arrested again what does it say yeah
when did he get arrested look at his
name well someone's gonna teach him but
what is going on with that neck that's
his real neck that is [ __ ] crazy
that's like he's got a double neck maybe
he just says a small jaw
no that is a big neck whatever his
parents look like um I bet they have
giant next to but that Shailaja never
dad mom moms
old odd-looking lady first please
mugshot showed off his really big neck
this time he's not smiling so it's the
same same yeah so he's probably power
lift or something like that
yeah and plus got a fucked-up neck what
a dream they don't know no need to blow
his poor man spot up all right [ __ ] up
neck but I take his neck over the skinny
neck no I with you know I maybe his neck
is like genetically [ __ ] up like that
and maybe the guy with the skinny neck
just doesn't work out like the situation
that's that's what it's not it doesn't
bug me when somebody is just they have
you know a slender neck but when they go
through so much trouble to look like an
alpha male right but they have that
little chicken neck right and then
they're posing like there that's gotta
be my issue with you